Amazon Prime's video streaming service
is carving out a reputation for itself
as the premier stop for quality sci-fi
content between recent original series
like upload and tales from the loop and
strategic acquisitions like the expanse
it's a good time to be an Amazon
subscriber with a geek streak the
surprise hit currently burning up the
charts on Amazon Prime video certainly
fits into this pattern it's called the
vast of night a 2019 sci-fi film that
sadly never had the chance to reach the
wide audience that it deserved in
theaters set in the 1950s in New Mexico
the vast of night centers around a
switchboard operator named fake rock and
a radio DJ called Everett when the two
teenagers discover a strange audio
frequency the team up to investigate its
origins
James Montague and Craig W Sanger
co-wrote the vast of night which is the
directorial debut of Andrew Patterson
with a keen eye and a unique approach to
directing Patterson demonstrates serious
cinematic chops it's no wonder the movie
won the Audience Award for Best
narrative feature at slam dance and was
a runner-up for People's Choice at the
Toronto International Film Festival
audiences and critics don't always agree
about the quality of a new movie but the
vast of night is already a unanimous
crowd-pleaser
Peter Raynor of KPC sees film week said
it's remarkably sharp funny and ominous
a terrific debut I don't know it just
said very shyly the bow screening about
pocket Mark Kermode if the Guardian
agreed with that assessment adding that
a film with such an apparently familiar
narrative can keep us this intrigued is
a credit to the filmmakers particularly
Patterson from whom we should expect to
hear much more in the future
james berardinelli of reelviews
similarly emphasized the quality of the
film's storytelling even in the absence
of i burning visual effects saying it's
a stark reminder that ideas are more
important than production budgets and
crafting compelling science fiction now
that streaming audiences have the
opportunity to consume Patterson's
creation on mass the verdict is
officially in the vast of night is a
triumph it's a little counterintuitive
but so many sci-fi films fail because of
their bloated budgets and over reliance
on the dazzling visual effects often
comes at the expense of plot and
character development but Patterson is
clearly a filmmaker who understands that
story is everything while the vast of
night isn't a horror film it does have
plenty of tense moments and pervasive
sense of unease in an interview with
Vanity Fair Patterson opened up about
the spooky tales that influenced his
film beginning with the Kecksburg
incident of December 1965 he explained a
lot of the plot for Everett the DJ
character was inspired by the mystery
surrounding a situation called the
Kecksburg incident where a car sized
acorn shaped device dropped out of the
sky and a local DJ started getting calls
residents of the small town in
Pennsylvania believed that debris ended
up in the woods causing US military
members to perform a sweep
astronomers verified the streak in the
sky and seismographs recorded the sonic
booms that occurred but the Air Force
officially stated that nothing was found
describing the incident Patterson added
there's a part of the Kecksburg
mythology where they went and looked at
the trees where this item this acorn
thing smashed down and the branches are
still broken in ways that indicate
something very forceful ripped through
we wanted that in our movie other true
life events that inspired the vast of
night were the disappearances of three
teenagers that weren't solved until 44
years after the fact in 1970 Jimmy
Williams Thomas Michael Rios and Leah
Gayle Johnson went missing from Sayer
Oklahoma just a year after three other
adults from the area vanished without a
trace
law enforcement finally solved the
disappearances in 2013 using new sonar
equipment to discover both trios cars
submerged in a reservoir near the town
Patterson said both cars were found
right next to each other under 12 feet
of water with all the skeletons of the
missing parties accounted for that was
an important anecdote for me just
knowing that things like this do happen
and they have very logical explanations
clearly Patterson pulled a lot of
inspiration from the world around him if
the vast of night uh sure's in a new age
of plot driven science fiction
storytelling like many
leave it might then the future of the
genre will be a bright one indeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]